here's what would happen if you climb  the highest mountain in the solar system  well first you'd have to make the Trek  to Mars to climb the 25 kilometer High  Martian volcano Olympus Mons since  Mars's atmosphere is mostly carbon  dioxide even if you made it there in one  piece you'd need to wear a spacesuit  supplying you with oxygen but no need to  adjust oxygen levels for altitude during  your climb here the first leg of the  climb would be a nearly vertical Cliff  after that your path would flatten out  but it would still take about 30 hours  of non-stop hiking to reach the summit  at the summit you'd experience a thin  atmosphere and wispy clouds of vapor  along with a collapsed crater the size  of Lake Ontario Olympus mods is three  times taller than Mount Everest and you  would be the first to save made the  climb successfully so